luego de cinco días en Caracas los jefes
de ambas delegaciones anuncian que fue
superado el impase suscitado el pasado
31 de diciembre luego que el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro anunciara un
cese al fuego bilateral que
posteriormente fue desmentido por la
guerrilla del eln tras leer un
comunicado conjunto confirmaron que el
próximo 13 de febrero inicia el segundo
ciclo de conversaciones en México que
podría extenderse entre tres semanas y
un mes Precisamente en esta segundo
ciclo de conversaciones uno de los temas
a tratar sería como llegar al cese al
fuego bilateral al ser consultado sobre
cuál es la presencia real de la
guerrilla del eln en territorio
venezolano el jefe de la delegación del
eln Pablo Beltrán se limitó a decir que
estaban en la frontera común en la raya
y no confirmó las denuncias sobre la
fuerte presencia de este grupo en
territorio venezolano ambas partes
agradecieron a los países garantes como
Cuba Noruega Venezuela y chile por su
participación en este proceso en esta
oportunidad del comunicado conjunto fue
leído en la casona antigua casa
presidencial